each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so welcome to a mr. Cambridge those who
have come from across the road gives me
great pleasure to introduce mike hicks
who was a visiting researcher here some
years ago 2008 Wow that's shocking it's
good to have my back he's gone on to
great things he had been at University
of Maryland he's now the director of the
Maryland cybersecurity Center professor
their leader of the plum group and he's
going to be speaking about this topic
dynamic enforcement of knowledge base
security policies my kicks thank you
very much glad to be here so my research
generally is about programming languages
and I've worked on many different topics
some listed up there I list these in
case any of you are interested in
talking about them with me later today
today I'm going to be focusing on
privacy-preserving computation and the
context of the of the talk is free sites
so the thing that's nice about facebook
or myspace or LinkedIn is it gives you a
way of using a free service to connect
with friends and colleagues it's easily
accessible and so on maybe the bad part
is that the service is not really free
it's being paid for by you free use of
the company of your personal information
say for targeted advertising so many
proposals have been put forth to try to
rectify this problem of avoiding the
third party holding your data so a one
example is PR xhv prpl not PRP I that
came out of Monica lambs group at
Stanford and the idea there is to have a
more decentralized approach where data
is stored on separate sort of agnostic
servers and users can talk to each other
individually rather than through a
central site personas work that was done
also at Maryland that takes the the prpl
model one step further and encrypts the
data that's stored on these swords
servers and then only those with
attribute keys is able are able to
decrypt them so all of this is fine
but ultimately it's limited we think by
the use of access control as the policy
you have to decide once and for all
whether someone can see this data or not
see it as opposed to having more
specialized release so just to
illustrate what I mean let's look at the
status quo with facebook right now what
will happen is some advertiser will
present some query some specification of
the demographic they'd like their ad
presented to they give that to Facebook
and then when I log into Facebook I see
the page that I'm looking at but also
adds and I may see for example this
photography companies ad if I match the
query that they sent to facebook now the
alternative strategy could be something
like well now the photography company
will send their query to Facebook and
then the query can be sent to you and
you can run the query locally and then
return back to Facebook whether or not
you displayed or clicked on the ad and
then that way Facebook can be paid for
having presented this ad but at the same
time you get to hold your data locally
to run the query so Facebook doesn't
have to own it anymore and this idea has
been proposed for example by the provide
system that came out of MPI yeah
somebody's not abusing the system know
if it's running on the computer then I
can just send queries and and answer the
wrong queries and no sorry lambda X
don't know so you could do that and you
can do that now it's there that you
already have this problem right you have
ad blockers and things like this and so
it's really no different I would claim
you can you can already lie about your
data people already do that the idea is
that it's in your interests to answer
truthfully as long as answering
truthfully does not compromise your
privacy because then you'll see ads that
you care about rather than ads that you
don't and you can always just block the
ads if you don't care to see ads okay so
let's for the for the purposes of
discussion remove facebook from the
picture and just imagine you're you're
interacting with an advertiser directly
and then we can step back and answer a
broader question of let's the pay let's
suppose that you're the curator of your
own data and now people instead of just
taking your data and doing whatever they
want with it they send queries to you to
ask to have access to the data in some
way and the problem that's put to you is
should I answer this query or not
is there some at some point am I going
to be revealing too much information and
answering the query whether that query
comes from an advertiser or anybody else
okay so as an example let's suppose for
this photography company the query is
well are you female engaged and young
because if so I would like to shoot the
photos for your wedding so maybe that's
fine that doesn't uniquely identify you
area there are many young women who are
engaged on the other hand if they asked
you for your that's a typo that should
be gender rather than age if they ask
you for your gender zip code and birth
date than in the United States this
would uniquely identify you sixty-three
percent of the time so that would be
information you would not want to
respond to in that particular query so
the question is how can I tell the
difference between the queries that are
going to ask for very little information
maybe a little bit more information and
then maybe a lot of information how do I
decide whether to how much information
is revealed by my query to decide
whether to answer it or not so the
approach that we take is to maintain a
representation of the query errs belief
about possible values so just as you
would have an access control policy for
different people that would interact
with your data you will likewise have a
belief representation that represents
what you think they know about your data
so with the example of Facebook you can
start off with demographic information
about Facebook users so that knowing
nothing else Facebook is likely to think
that you're young and you're male some
percent of the time less than female and
so on to set this initial belief ok so
then at that point when the person that
you're you've set this policy for starts
asking you questions you can decide by
whether or not the question would reveal
too much about your information by
revising this belief so we start off
with this representation we depict it as
a brain and we write it as a probability
we represented as a probability
distribution so it's the likelihood of
each of these values being some amount
how likely your mail how likely your
female what you're likely birth year is
and so on ok so then the query shows up
and you evaluate that query with respect
to this belief representation and you
get a revised belief that you can use
Bayesian reasoning to
produce and you can then decide has this
revealed too much information if the
answer is no then you can answer the
query and now you use the revised
representation for the subsequent query
if the next query comes in say it's that
second query that asks for too much
information then you can reject that
query retain the representation from
before answer the next one and so on so
that's the basic idea of the system that
we're developing a very tiny difference
but they kept asking your queries that
could make a big difference yes and so
that's why we maintain the
representation with each query so that
over time as the knowledge accumulates
eventually you'll you'll say no I'm not
going to vote the camel's back yes
that's exactly round I'm not going to
tell you anymore even though we doesn't
tell you anything much new that's
correct okay so you are queried person a
representation of the query quick query
knowledge of the world that's correct
and you make decisions informed
decisions according to what do you think
he thinks that's correct but what he
thinks could be different than what
that's true yes so this is a big
assumption that we're making in this
work so I think for systems like you
know these large online social networks
there are many sconset contexts where
you can come up with a reasonable
estimate of what the other person
believes about you so that you can make
decisions and I guess the other thing to
say is that you want to compare it
against the status quo which is you just
give them everything and you just trust
by some legal privacy policy that they
don't do the wrong thing the other point
is you can also use a system like this
as pointed out a little bit later to not
necessarily enforce policies where you
would direct queries but instead you
just track information that has been
released and in that case you can always
use sort of the entropy of the query
with respect to the prior queries to
represent how many sort of bits of
information have been released right so
for in particular you can always set the
initial be believed to be the uniform
distribution that it could be one of any
possible number of things and then each
query that's going to conservatively
maximize the amount of information
that's communicated when you respond to
queries and you can just keep track over
time of how much information is being
released and the decide retro actively
say hey I just had this big privacy
breach with all these people I was
interacting with to whom did I release
too much information and then you could
use that to audit the result so then in
that case your initial estimation is not
so important I guess I'll say one other
thing which is you don't have to
maintain just one belief this is not
work that we've spent a whole lot of
time thinking about you can maintain
multiple beliefs if you think instead of
one probability distribution they have
one of many possible beliefs our
representation for beliefs actually
allows you to do that to say to
represent many possible distributions
and then you just do this whole process
on all the distributions instead okay so
the idea the contributions of this work
our first this idea of knowledge-based
policies where you maintain a belief and
you answer or do not answer a query
based on how much information you
believe the adversary is gaining and
then the second is we implemented this
idea using a new kind of probabilistic
interpretation of executing a
probabilistic programs based on abstract
interpretation so basically we define a
method that you can think of as a
functor that takes a regular abstract
domain and turns it into a probabilistic
abstract domain so that we can do the
belief revision and everything else that
I was just talking about so those are
the two two main contributions of the
work at the end of the talk if I have
time I'll talk about an extension of
this work beyond this sort of Facebook
context to working with multiple parties
who are all participating in some
computation where they each present
secrets rather than in this case where
only one person has a secret and the
other person has a query okay so let's
let's step through how the technique
works so here's Bob Bob was born on sep
tember 24th 1980 and that's represented
there at the top in terms of b day in
the year and we're going to represent
the adversaries belief as this uniform
distribution that his birthday is
between 0 and 360 for could be any day
of the year and his birth year is
nineteen fifty six to nineteen ninety
two so we could represent any
distribution we want I'm just using the
simple one to make the exposition easier
okay so now let's suppose that cakes
calm sends Bob a query that says if this
week is your birthday
I want to provide you a special offer so
it asks whether today being day to 60 if
Bob's birthday is this week if so it
returns one saying showing the ad
otherwise don't show on the ad so we can
see at the top there Bob's belief Bob's
actual birthday is the little orange
square and the answer of the query is
not Bob's birthday is not this week and
so we're going to actually produce zero
running the query would answer with zero
now revising the belief of cakes com we
would get this distribution that's shown
at the bottom right Bob's birthday is
not this week so we slice out this week
as the possible birthday where the
x-axis is birthday and the y-axis is
birth year so the question is is that ok
is that revealing too much information
or not ok so the way we define ok is we
use what we call a knowledge threshold
and intuitively speaking i'm going to
refine this in a minute we want the
probability that the adversary ascribes
to my secret to be less than a threshold
that we call the knowledge threshold so
and the choice of tea depends on your
the risk you ascribe to revelation of
your secret so in this particular case
let's suppose that Bob sets his
threshold to one-fifth for his birthday
I want you to not know me within 5 1 a
one-in-five chance for the day of the
year and then the particular combination
of birthday and berthier together as one
in 20 ok so why would we do that why not
have policies for each one of them well
it's because when you have these tuple
policies it gives you the opportunity to
allow the query er a bit more utility
right so what this is saying is that I'm
okay with you knowing my either my
birthday or my birth year to some fine
degree as long as you don't know the
other one because in knowing both you're
going to be no more of that would be
able to uniquely identify me and I'm
going to put some limit on birthday to
never be better than one in five but you
could learn up to that amount as long as
you don't learn too much about the birth
year or vice versa okay so you have a
little more flexibility there so right
now currently the probability of the
birthday is one in 365 and the
probability of the pair of them is 11 in
365 x 37 both of those are clearly less
than the thresholds and so
we're good now after the query the
revised belief looks like this on the
bottom and so should we answer the query
and the answer is yes because they are
within the threshold the birthday is now
one in 358 because we carved out this
one week and the the pair of the two of
them is clearly a whole lot less than
one in 20 and so everything is fine and
we answer the question in knowing your
exact birthday right that's correct so
Pete you know in knowing your precise
secret would it make a difference if you
you know who cared about him not knowing
you know that your birthday was in
November you know sort of some region
but because you're saying provide he
doesn't ever vote yes yes so that so yes
I so you could do that so you could
basically define a tuple in some senses
is a special case of a more general
predicate that you could define over
your secret that you want the certainty
of this predicate of the answer of this
predicate being less than a certain
threshold so you could easily extend it
to do that the birthday is just a set of
a single element yeah and you can have
another secret which is a measurable set
subset of Europe right so you can use
the predicate and you could run it on
the probability distribution which would
then give you a probability of the
answer of that and you could say that
that needs to be less than the threshold
okay so now let's go to the next day so
the next day is day 2 61 and then cakes
calm answers asks the same question and
this time now we are within the week of
Bob's birthday and so we're going to get
the answer as one instead of 0 and then
after belief revision we're going to get
that revised belief at the bottom okay
so that's bad because now the
probability that the adversary knows the
birthday is one so we ought to reject
the query okay but does anyone see the
problem from the query errs perspective
let's assume that the query irnos my
policy he knows that my threshold is is
one in 50 or in fact as any reasonable
threshold right any threshold that's not
one then the query ER is going to know
that the only reason that I would reject
is if today if 267 is my birthday okay
so I put myself I back myself into a
corner because rejection now
and I'm once they've asked the wrong
question I'm stuck so the problem is
that this is sort of obvious once you
think about it the problem is that my
decision about whether to accept or
reject the definition of my security
policy depends on my secret so whether I
accept or not reveals potentially
information about my secret and in this
case it reveals far too much so what we
want is we want the decision to accept
or reject to be independent of the
actual secret and therefore the that
decision won't ever leaked any
information so we can do it this way we
can say for every possible output oh and
every possible birthday be it needs to
be less than the threshold and if that's
true I'll accept otherwise I won't in
other words if there exists a birthday
whether it's my birthday or not such
that rejection would reveal too much so
sorry such that answering would reveal
too much then we reject so the idea then
is that even if Bob's birthday is not to
67 let's say it's some other place over
here we're still going to reject the
second query because there exists a
birthday that would back us into a
corner so this is this methodology where
you make the security policy independent
and secret is called simulate able
auditing it's a way that the adversary
knowing what our representation of his
belief is and our threshold knows
whether or not the query is going to be
answered he doesn't even need to send us
the query at all he'll know whether it's
going to be answered or not and so
therefore it can't possibly leak any
information about our secret if you can
do it himself so yeah listing approach
life where you really toss a coin as
well as looking at the feather
information sometimes you sometimes you
make lose any weight so you could do
that I think I'm going to have an
example later on that shows how that
would work so for this particular
example the first query we're always
going to accept no matter what your
birthday is you'll always accept because
it will always be within the policy the
second query you'll always reject no
matter what your birthday is because
there exists a birthday that's in bad
shape and then it turns out that the
third query given that we accepted and
rejected the first to it we will
actually accept once we get two day 266
and you can again do a calculation that
says well if your birthday whether it's
0 or 1 you'll never do better than
knowing one in five or one in 353
depending on what your birthday is okay
so so we implement this by using an
abstract interpretation methodology the
idea is that we could so we could use
really any probabilistic computation
approach so the way that this the way
that we implement these queries is we
run the query using the belief so we
basically instead of having a the
program via a function from states to
States which is the way it's been
looking the way I've been writing it
here you can think of this little
program all of these global variables
are referring to a state and so at the
end of the program the state whether out
is one or zero is is the result that
we're using so it's from states to
States and so what we want to do is we
want to run it on over distributions of
states rather than regular states and
the simplest way you can think of to do
that is to actually try every possible
state right so I could basically run my
program actually I think I have a I
could do this right I could take the
program and I can sample every possible
input state and run it and produce the
output state and do that enough times
that I'm able to figure out what the
output distribution is from the input
distribution and if i want to have
perfect clarity about what the output
distribution is i need to actually
sample all of the states at least up to
the point of being able to make a sound
decision about the threshold okay so
that would be slow right is it because
it's now a function of the size of the
state space
so instead what we do is we we avoid
this because sampling based
interpretation is going to be too slow
and so we developed an abstract
interpretation methodology that allows
us to have a more compressed or more
compact representation of distributions
to make things more efficient so I'm
going to show you how that works ok so
our abstract domain is going to be what
we call probabilistic polyhedra so
polyhedra is a normal abstract domain is
quite common and what we do is we add
probabilities to this domain so the idea
is you're going to represent a
probabilistic polyhedra as a bunch of
linear constraints that describe this
shape and then you're going to add to it
a measure of the probability of each
point we're interpreting this discreetly
every state is we're only considering
discrete distributions so every point
inside of this space has this
probability ok so this is the simplest
representation you can imagine of a
probabilistic polyhedra the probability
of each point and the inside the shape
and the definition of the shape and then
what happens is after we do that's
correct that's right so after as we're
doing our execution and our belief
revision and so on we're going to end up
getting you know states that look like
this we're here we now have three
probabilistic polyhedra and the points
that you know the ones inside of here
have a certain probability the ones in
here have a certain probability
represented by these numbers down here
ok so that's the that's the basic idea
is the polygons see and the probability
per point expecting to see something
more there's something more distribution
like that their belief about you know my
birthday might be initially uniform and
gradually becomes more humpy yeah so it
will but but this is very discreet this
is you know uniform within the polygons
and zero outside kind of like oh oh oh
sure it fair enough so so if you start
off so you can certainly start off with
a non-uniform distribution and then as
you perform belief revision you're going
to basically be slicing off parts of
that distribution right the point is
that you're gaining the adversary is
gaining more and more knowledge about
you and so if you don't have any coin
flips inside of your programs if your
programs look like the program's I
showed you all you're going to be doing
is making that distribution smaller and
smaller by slicing points off not
changing the probabilities of any point
now once you add coin flips to your
language then you add uncertainty coin
flips once you had probabilistic choice
to your language then you will start
introducing more humpy distributions and
I'll show you what that looks like in a
minute because we do any of that you
said there's nothing to stop you having
non uniform distributions but this can't
describe non-uniform distribution can
you can just make a it's a they're
always discreet but you can make it so
that each polygon has different so that
the total probability of polygons yeah
lots of little polygons right that's
what this is ok right and they can each
have different probability mass that
then makes this one more likely than
this one than this one and this one
gasps your distribution uh sort of
single number that describes that yes so
we would have we were we have a discrete
representation of this single number
that represents this I guess I have
really thought very much about you you
could take advantage of representing
things more compactly in that way ok so
so we could just stop there and have
these representations many polygons but
actually that would be inefficient that
over time as I was saying you're going
to be slicing up this space quite a lot
and you'll generate many many polygons
and it'll become more and more expensive
to perform the computation so we need
some way of doing abstraction so what we
do is we we allow collapsing regions so
that what was two polygons can now be
contained in one polygon but now we have
to change our representation because
before implicitly every point within the
polygon was in play every possible point
had the same probability whereas now
that's no longer true it now maybe that
when I draw a box around two regions
that were there before some points are
more likely than other points so this is
just to illustrate how we might end up
with too many regions it's going to
happen with dis junks so here this is
the state that we were in after that
first query that i just showed when we
sliced out the week and now let's
suppose that this this crazy guy here
sends us this query
says well if you have a decade year if
your birthday this year is going to make
you 20 or 30 or 40 or 50 or 60 then
return true or else false and on
returning true i guess ansari in
returning false in this case we're going
to end up having this as our
representation right because we sliced
out all of those possible decades okay
so then that's why we're going to want
to do the subtraction so here's the
representation that we would have had if
we had every possible one and now here
we could go back to a more compact
representation where we draw a box
around both of those sets of polygons
but then what we need to do is we need
to put a bound on the total size of the
number of points inside the polygon so
the complete area of this polygon would
be 9620 but because actually a bunch of
the lines in here are missing we're
going to bound the size as 85-82 say
that this represents all distributions
that have points in this space such that
there are only 85 80 points okay so this
is an abstraction this abstraction
represents this distribution but it also
represents a bunch of other
distributions that are going to cause us
to behave conservatively yes so this is
not the first obstruction that came to
my mind when I saw this okay and I'm
wondering why why didn't use the first
obstruction which is you just take the
bounding rectangle and Yuri normalize
everything so that the thumbs are would
be same so you actually renormalize p
and you say that oh I'm going to be a
little over approximately the
probability of some value inside a
rectangle would that work nice so so
we're going to get to that so maybe I
chose the wrong pedagogical approach to
get to closer to the one that you're
thinking of so why don't we get to the
end and then we can have this
conversation again okay so this is just
illustrating that this represents
multiple distributions okay so another
thing that can happen so now this goes
to your question Andy and also to Simon
about the probability of points being
different in our language we permit coin
flips so what this says is we're going
to do the same query as before but then
one time out of 10 we're just going to
slit set output to true okay so P if
takes a rational number some number
between 0
in one and then it has a biased coin
flip to that amount with that
probability okay so then what's going to
happen is this is in the query yes so
why would the query I want to do this
okay so you more likely to say yes is
that yes that gives you less information
that's right but you otherwise you'll
just saying no I CC messing up your quit
messing up his own query correct in
order to persuade you to be nice to him
that's right but another way to look at
it is in some ways we don't care whether
we add the noise or the query or ads the
noise but if we add the noise probably
to make it worth our while so that the
utility would be worthwhile we would
want to tell the querier that we added
noise to the to the query so I think you
could go with either argument I think I
like it better that the query or adds
his own noise because then you knows how
to account for the noise so in fact I'll
just digress for a moment one our
approach is aiming to avoid trusted
third parties right we don't we want to
get rid of facebook and everybody has
their own data okay so there's this
other approach to privacy that I'm sure
you've heard of called differential
privacy which looks at privacy of
databases ie a trusted third party and
so you send queries to this database
they add noise to the result and they
send you the result back I'm saying
let's let's avoid third parties all
together let's everybody have their own
data but now the question is if you have
that scenario how can you produce
aggregates because asking each
individual for their record in the
database is going to violate their
personal privacy policy right if I
wanted to compute the average salary in
the department how do I do it without
asking each one of you for your salary
which is going to violate your privacy
policy so the answer is you can do it by
adding random coin flips to it well
there's a technique called randomized
response where you say what is your
salary flip a coin if it comes out heads
tell me the truth if it comes out tails
then dussehra several other coin flips
to perturb the actual number so I never
respond to you with certainty as to what
my actual salary is and because you know
how I did the coin flips you can account
for that when performing the aggregate
so people develop this as a survey
technique to ask sensitive questions
like you know are you having an affair
are you I don't know stealing from the
company whatever it might be so that
people will answer truthfully so you
could actually do the same thing and
that would be a reason for why the
adversary might insert their own coin
for
ok so anyway here we are we now have
these these regions that have different
probability points in them right the
reason that you would say true is is
very likely because it is your birth
year or whatever but there is some
chance that in these gaps you that those
are also possible because you said too
because of the coin flip so in this case
we need to extend our definition of
region so here you go here's your bound
on probability because the probability
of points could be could differ inside
ok so it turns out that we can do we
need to do even more than that so we end
up having we bound three additional
properties of the region's one is we
bound the probability of each point we
bound the total size the total number of
points in the region and we also bound
the total probability mass within the
region so this is redundant you know you
don't need to do this so just the first
two are sufficient for having a
reasonable abstraction but it turns out
that by doing this we can get more
precision that there are times when some
operations that you want to perform that
maintaining the probability mask is
easier and more precise than than just
the probability times the size so we
maintain all of these as upper bounds
and also as lower bounds and the reason
is that when we do conditioning so that
the case when I ran the query and I said
oh in the case that output is 1 I need
to divide the probability distribution
and in order to soundly approximate what
the adversaries belief is I need to
under approximate the distribution that
I'm dividing by or else I'll under
approximate what the adversary knows so
I need to maintain upper and lower
bounds in both cases and in fact this
it's this well there's several aspects
of this representation that are novel
but this is the most important
difference between prior work on
probabilistic abstract interpretation
and what we're doing is that none of
them consider conditioning or
observations ok so just to give you a
sense of how the abstract interpretation
work so it's all kinds of if you were to
look at our paper you would see all of
this math and geometry about computing
you know when you add to probabilistic
polyhedra together and you draw a
bounding box around them what is the new
sighs what's the new probability mass
so here's an example if we were to add
p1 and p2 to get p3 how would we compute
P 3 well first we'd have to compute the
convex hull of c1 and c2 that is those
shapes we'd have to merge them together
and make the result convex and then we
would ask okay well what's the smallest
possible and the greatest possible
overlap because remember not every point
in those two shapes is necessarily in
play so we look at the most optimistic
overlap and the most pessimistic overlap
we also look based on whether overlap as
possible how that's going to affect the
probability of the points for example if
you completely overlapped then basically
you're going to add the minimum
probabilities together for those two
points you're just going to double the
probability mass but if there's only
partial overlap then you can't do that
and you have to maintain sort of the
least lower bound of the one side or the
other and so on you just make all of you
have to just put your thinking cap on
and work through all of this geometry
and then do your soundness proof to make
sure that you that you got it right what
is this excuse was it has to use the
number of number of points inside there
when is the size used yeah um it's let
me think about them bones are so it's
used it's used in projection so when you
do an assignment in your language so you
say x equals something what you'll end
up doing is you'll have some
representation for X in your shape and
if you have a non-invertible assignment
so the right hand side doesn't mention X
at all you're going to collapse
everything you know about X right so
you're going to have some shape and you
have this x axis and you're going to
smush everything this way and you need
to know how many points you just
compressed on to this one axis from the
axis that you got rid of in order to
boost the probability per point in the
projected amount so that's where the
size comes in and basically what we do
is we end up computing we use the size
and we also look at the shape to figure
out what's the maximum and the minimum
sort of extent of the axis that we're
compressing and we use that to set the
new probabilities in that in that place
okay so the biggest mostly we're able to
do I mean most of this is simple
arithmetic and using existing abstract
interpretation library so we use
something
parma to do all of the polyhedral
operations like the convex hull the
other thing we have to do is counting we
have to look well how many points are
inside of this space what's the minimum
and maximum extent and so on and so we
use a tool called latte that does this
geometric counting for us it turns out
that latte is not very good software
like it's buggy and it crashes and it's
really slow and well I'll say more about
that later this is these are
obstructions yes so all you know is that
there are these two polyhedra that that
kind of visibly overlapping and you
imagine that all the points were is far
yes yes with the overlap as possible I
see so you know nothing about the
internal structure echt because it's an
abstraction exactly i see so that's why
you say it's really just simple
arithmetic okay right so this is an
illustration of what's going on with
this so this is sort of the concrete
representation of these two
distributions and when you overlap them
intuitively these points are now more
likely than these points because you've
added the two distributions together so
what will happen if you have a
probabilistic polyhedral representation
of this so here's see one and here's see
two and the size of these things if
every point was represented is 140 but
let's suppose for example that while
every point in c1 is represented in situ
we're only going to we will only 30
points or in play so in this case the
the total number of points is going to
be 130 we're just going to add them
together in that in the vent in the
maximal case right if there's no overlap
between them and then yeah so then this
just shows where the intersection is
could be 20 around here and so then
that's going to cause us to to change
the maximum to 120 yeah so what this is
saying is that if I stupidly just added
these two points together these two
things together it would be sound for me
to say the maximum is 130 but that would
be in precise because there's no way
with these two shapes given these two
shapes would ever have more than 120
points and so that's one place where we
can change the size to be 120
okay so um the main thing to take away
from this slide that I haven't already
talked about is that polyhedra are just
a moat sort of most expressive kind of
shape that you could use for
representation there are other shapes
that are cheaper to represent but lose
precision so these are intervals where
you have no relations at all between
axes you just have lower and upper
bounds on on variables and octagons
which have this representation you can
only have a relation between two
variables that's a linear relationship
so it turns out that octagon czar really
useful in practice I just came from ens
and they never use polyhedra they only
use octagons so anyway sure enough
octagons are a fine representation to
use although in our case actually
intervals turns out to be really good
too okay so we did a bunch of
experiments so I've already shown you a
bunch of these the birthday query the
second day birthday query and then the
special query that slices out the the
decade years and then we had several
other queries that we all got from
facebook said this photo and travel one
come from examples on the facebook
webpage of what advertisers right and
this pizza one was you know of course
college students want to know where the
closest pizza joint is so if you live
within some play some distance and your
college student you know tell me all the
pizza show me the ad for this pizza
location okay so i'm going to show you
two graphs the first one just shows you
something that should be intuitively
obvious which is that if you were to
implement this by enumeration if you
were to do the silly thing that i showed
you in the beginning of sampling all the
points and running at all that's going
to be slow so this y-axis shows the
belief that you would have right so when
I'm going to do the threshold query
check I'm going to see does the average
does the adversaries probability is it
less than my threshold and the more I
sample the more certain I can be about
the belief right if I'd only sample
one-third of all of the points in the
distribution then I have to
conservatively assume that the other
two-thirds are going to go against me
and the belief is going to be much
higher and so you see that's what's
happening here that over time as the
sampling approach works it goes better
and better until finally it hits the
best possible precision here by sampling
the entire space after six
17 seconds where's when we use
probabilistic polyhedra that all of
these little spate these shapes here
represent a bound on the number of
probabilistic polyhedra that we will
allow right until we have to start
coalescing them and abstracting so if
the bound is one we're here and if the
bound is I think 35 then we're here to
the right so what this is showing is
that whatever the bound is we get
maximal precision on just with one
polyhedron in this particular case and
it will take upwards of four seconds to
compute compared to 16 seconds now the
interesting thing is here is the same
query but now we'll change the state
space so that the birthday is between
1910 and 2010 rather than 56 and 92 so
we just made the space base a whole lot
bigger so basically it's going to take
the same amount of time for our
abstraction because it's just you know
just as easy to count it whereas
sampling is you know it basically the
program crashed after 36 seconds of
doing sampling right so this just shows
the limitation of a sampling based
approach ok so this this graph is
showing the precision performance
trade-off of the three different shape
representations either polyhedra
octagons or intervals so this is
intervals this is octagons this is
polyhedra and the y-axis is the time
that it takes to perform the query and
the x-axis is the number of shapes that
we are allowed so the intuition is is
you move to the right you'll get better
precision but your performance will get
worse so you can basically see this
upward trend of performance getting
worse as we have more and more shapes so
this motivates the abstraction in the
first place the size of the the shapes
here represents the precision so a dot
represents the best possible precision
and a big box represents the work a bad
precision I think there's maybe four
different possibilities that were you
know we discretized it for the purposes
of the graph and then these things are
showing these are the median of several
runs and this is showing the semi
interquartile range between them ok so
the takeaway is basically if you have a
small number of polyhedra so this is
with the sequence of three queries then
you have lousy precision but then you
get really lucky here at three you get
the best possible precision and in all
three cases
these little dots and pretty good
performance but then things start to get
worse again and then finally they get
better here at the end when there's no
bound so I'll say something about why
that hat why that is later this graph at
the bottom is just zooming in on this
part of this graph to show the precise
difference with intervals that you can
see the upward trend again here but the
running times are much better right
they're all less than a second and we
still get the best possible precision
okay so then this is basically the
running times for all these different
approaches and you can see intervals do
the best why is that it's counting okay
so lattes is the reason what this graph
shows is that as the number of
constraints that represent your shape
increases the time this is an
exponential sorry a logarithmic scale
the time is super exponential okay so
you just get killed with counting if you
have really complicated shapes and so
this so it makes sense then why when you
use intervals you don't have this
problem anymore because counting is a
piece of cake when all you have is boxes
right you have squares or three
dimension four dimensional five
dimensional boxes it's a piece of cake
to count how many points go in there and
so that's why intervals are really
really fast octagons should be a little
bit faster but it seems that Lotte
doesn't take advantage of the simpler
constraints and so it's not that much
faster we tried to develop our own
counting procedure for octagons but
couldn't get something that worked in
every case and so we eventually
abandoned it okay so the last thing that
I'll say is we have we notice this this
trend where the precision fluctuates
here why is that it turns out that the
reason is that the order that you choose
to merge the polygons while you're
executing your program right so you hit
an if statement you split you do the
then branch in the else branch each of
those gets to say ten polygons you merge
together so now you have ten polygons
that you have two on each side that you
have to merge down to ten polygons to
maintain your bound well how do you do
that well basically you just point wise
add together those polygons but you have
many choices about which pairs to add
when you merge them together it will
always be sound but it turns out it will
hurt your precision right so you have
two polygons that are largely
overlapping and you add them together
you'll lose very little precision but if
they're all the way over here and you
all this big box around them you're
going to lose a lot of precision that
way so what this shows is that when you
have only one polygon there's no choices
and your precision is complete crap so
this is the again this is the best
possible belief is here toward the
bottom and then this is the number of
this is the bound for using intervals
the box is the median and the lower and
upper bounds are how bad or good you
could get in terms of precision so what
this shows is that for all the
experiments that I showed before the
things that were on the plot were these
medians and for each of the bounds and
what this is showing is that if you
tried some other combination of merging
them together you could get dramatically
different precision right so for example
in this case the median with three is
really terrible but you could get really
lucky and make it all the way down here
to the bottom so the merging order
really really matters and the difficulty
is coming up with a good heuristic to
decide how to merge because if you you
could do something very complicated to
compute hey this is a good idea to merge
but then of course you hurt yourself
because you spend all this time figuring
out whether it emerging you how to just
do it so my understanding is that this
is sort of an open problem a black art
kind of problem in abstract
interpretation generally and we just
make it worse because of the counting
and everything else that goes on top of
it okay so I'm going to spend just five
minutes talking about how we could
generalize this idea to multiple parties
and I won't tell you any of the details
and i'll refer you to this class paper
if you care to look at them so we were
interested in again in this world view
of decentralized computation of say
people with mobile phones or something
wanting to compute answers like for
example are you and I at the same
location okay I don't want to reveal to
you where I am I just want to know if
you happen to be sitting in the same
restaurant as me okay so how can I do
that well I could do this so the query
here could be are we at the same
location or a classic example for secure
multi-party computation is the
millionaire's problem where these two
martini sippers are trying to decide
who's richer
out telling the other person what their
actual net worth is so one thing we
could do is we could get a trusted third
party to answer this question right we
could go to know Abraham Lincoln and say
can you please tell us i'll give you my
salary and you can tell us truthfully
which of us is richer but the crypto
people have figured out a way to do it
without a trusted third party where they
can use something called garbled
circuits or you could use homomorphic
encryption or other methods to compute
this just the two of them such that the
only thing you learn about the inputs is
what you can infer from the output but
you otherwise don't see the inputs okay
that's cool however you could learn
quite a lot from the output right this
is something that the crypt don't people
just leave aside oh well you can't see
the inputs yeah but what if the output
tells you a whole lot about what the
input is maybe you don't want to
participate in the query so you could
use the knowledge the belief style
policy in this setting just like we did
in the setting i showed before where
each participant could then decide based
on what they think the other participant
knows about their secret whether they
should participate or not or whether
they should just say no okay so I'm just
going to skip this
so the way that this works and this is
of course more difficult now because
when you are making a local decision you
don't have the entire query to look at
anymore you have the query minus the
other guys secret so you have to somehow
be able to make a decision without
knowing exactly what the other person
secret could be so the obvious thing to
do would be we is to do this it's to
imagine well if the other person secret
is 10 or 11 or 12 or 13 or 14 or 15 or
whatever it would be then the query
would be this and so therefore I can
consider each of those possible cases to
decide whether or not I should
participate and in fact all of these
possible beliefs all of these possible
cases we can actually just represent as
a probability distribution right where
we can say not only am I am I going to
have a probability distribution for what
the adversary thinks about my belief i'm
going to use a probability distribution
about what i think about their belief
i'm going to merge the two things
together and do the belief tracking to
decide what should happen it turns out
that using this approach is going to is
going to be very conservative because
it's going to say if the adversary if
there exists a secret that the adversary
could have such that the adversary
thinks that there exists a secret that I
could have that could violate the policy
then I'm going to say no so it just
turns out you'll say no a lot of the
time in this case so an alternative that
we is will solve this problem is to
actually do the belief tracking as part
of the smc that is imagine that you have
a trusted third party who's going to
know what you know and know what the
adversary with the other person knows
and know what your secrets are and then
tell you whether answering the question
will reveal too much okay and that will
all happen inside of this sort of
trusted third party as part of the
protocol right so the whole process that
I showed you before of probabilistically
executing the program and doing belief
revision and everything else that's
going to all happen as part of the smc
so that you can only ever learn
something about the output and not
anything about the inputs so I won't
know what the adversary secret is
because I won't be able to see it as
part of the smc
huh
real ganna missions
so it turns out that this this is much
more permissive than use it then sort of
enumerated all of the other of the
adversaries possible values the problem
is I think this is only a theoretical
interest because secure multi-party
computation is already literally a
thousand times slower than normal
computation and now we're saying let's
do probabilistic interpretation which is
more than a thousand times slower than
regular interpretation and let's do it
all together in this in this setting but
on the other hand it could be that for
some for queries that happen
infrequently enough and are of
sufficient import it still want to do it
okay and in the in that paper there's an
empirical analysis of these two ways of
doing things and showing how the
precision improvement occurs for the
second case and not the first and so on
okay so that's it so I've talked about
knowledge-based security policies and
how we can implement them using we call
belief tracking using abstract
interpretation and performance with
intervals seems reasonable though it can
always be improved especially when
dealing with this overlap business and
that's it
yep what when you should I see we're
thinking about the agent is important
this if you talk to chaotic urban and
think about whether you should answer
their queries and then you talk to
something else I've come you have to
sort have a think whether there is
communication between these guys and so
something should i think so everybody
asked me this question and i realized
that the thing that i find amusing about
this is that no one real and no one
thinks that access control has exactly
the same policy so let's imagine we
don't use this crazy thing and we just
have access control and so people say
hey can I see your data yes you can see
my data I trust you well they could do
the same thing they could take your
whole data and ship it off to somebody
else that really the problem is no
different in our setting then community
to the managed to get from different
sources no I know and they could do that
with accent well too so so let's say I'm
willing to tell you my birthday and I'm
willing to tell Andy my birth year and
we use regular access control policies
that make no mention of beliefs if I
presented to you that system I almost
can guarantee you that nobody would ask
me the question about collusion and it's
only because we use these brains and we
represent what you can infer about
things that people think huh well there
are other ways that I could infer them
like if I talk to my friends who also
talk to you so it's a fair point
collusion is important what I'm saying
is that it's no different in our setting
than in any system in which you have a
security policy that applies to one
principle differently than another
principle they can always collude to
share information that you didn't want
one of them to have about the other yeah
by you being partially anonymous to
whoever's asking the question he doesn't
he doesn't get to ask you this many quit
as many questions as once because at
some point you say not I'm not going to
answer any of your questions but this
person who does not exist and you can
ask me again right nothing without
knowing who I was before yeah so for
something like Facebook where the
advertisers really don't care about you
personally yeah that could work that's
it that's an interesting idea yep
understanding emerging problem
embarrassed say they don't understand
exactly because so in terms of geometry
the convex hull of just a bunch of
polygons is going to be there bounding
polygon anyway so yes so that doesn't
matter so so what is exactly but it's
the precision that matters right so if I
have if I let's say I have seven
polygons and I have to smoosh them down
to six okay so now what I want to do is
I'm going to retain many of these well I
have many choices to convert 726 right I
need to draw a box around some pair of
them joining was always converting a
bunch of polygons to one that's not true
no no I wouldn't wanna do that because
ni would lose a whole lot of precision
right oh how do you choose it's random
oh maybe it's whatever order they happen
to be in the list that we're maintaining
and you wouldn't want it you would not
want to literally randomize it I don't
think because because the performance it
is so dramatically and the precision is
so dramatically different that I think
would be very frustrating that if
somebody asks you a question you say no
they could have tits like you're you
know the kid that asked one parent then
asks the other parent oh yeah sure
that's fine that you really want it to
be deterministic and you just want to
make the best choice you can know how
many polygons you should merge where to
write so you have like seven polygons
you don't know should I immersion one or
two or three yeah even that choice even
that choice is not clear that's right so
to address the kind of collusion just
maintain one release date about what
cutter everyone knows that's right right
so that would be really conservative
right in again you could say the same
thing with access control I could have
one access control policy for the whole
world which would basically mean I'm
gonna say nothing to anyone right
because I'm not going to tell Facebook
the same things I would tell my wife
although your system maybe lets you kind
of partition of the rules slightly work
yes yes you could say there are some
people we know they might talk to each
other but you're not going to talk to
these Co so okay so this is this is a
good point so one thing I hinted at
before is that you can maintain a
representation of multiple beliefs to
hedge your bets against this kind of
collusion and you could we've just been
talking about it that our abstraction
already represents multiple
distributions right so you could take
advantage of that by using our
abstraction to represent many
distributions that represent the
possible beliefs of the adversary with
or without collusion for example the
problem is that while that sounds good
our particular representation is not
optimized to do that and it will be very
imprecisely like we we tried to do that
with this multi-party stuff and we just
always said no because the way that we
collapse the distributions turned out to
be pathologically bad but I think that
would be in angle for future work yeah
that's right notorious public access
enjolras is pretty good the policy I
mean the particular policy ladies
probabilities yeah where does the
threshold come from yeah so so i don't i
don't understand privacy policies so
i'll tell you that maybe you guys have
used this trick to the standard trick in
computer science research when something
boils down to a policy problem is you
make a system that allows many possible
policies and say hey people can encode
any policy they want they can do this
policy or this policy or this policy and
they leave aside the question of well is
that a useful policy no idea I have no
idea whether it's useful policy I don't
think anybody knows what a good privacy
policy is because I don't think people
know what the value of private
information is I mean people like
Facebook advertisers have some sense of
the monetization of your private
information and how much your social
security number is worth your birthday
or your gender or your bank account
number because you can sell those on the
black market but in terms of for example
the future proof value of your
information maybe it's not worth
anything now but in five years when they
can sequence your genome that personal
information might be very valuable I
just I don't know so really this is just
saying we want it we want to not have
something that's all or nothing where
it's either you give them everything or
you just keep it all to yourself and so
it allows you to hedge your bets and do
principle of least privilege a little
bit more but in terms of the exact value
at which that set the threshold I don't
know personal preference I know that's
not very satisfying I wish I had a
better answer
Beijing recently like it's ready to go
to primers yes yes yeah so that where do
you get the prior belief so when you're
doing this this facebook stuff or when
you're an anonymous face in the crowd
you can get demographic information that
says the likelihood of you fitting in
some sign of some sort of mold and I
think that will work although the funny
thing is that if this were to take off
and become the way to do things we
wouldn't have that information anymore
right because I wouldn't be sharing it
so then you then you really wouldn't be
able to determine the priors but at the
moment I think they're there are public
sources of information you could use for
at least some services that would give
you a reasonable prior but if you were
if you're worried about interacting with
someone who might have auxiliary
information about you you know it's
going to be very hard to estimate what
that would be but assuming that they
could know any auxiliary information is
used this is basically what differential
privacy does yields essentially zero
utility I mean any any attempts of
applying differential privacy to the
sorts of more personal data release
situations that I've been talking about
gives you zero utility so that's no good
either so again hard problem i'm not
sure okay well let's think i might for a
great talk